well
the metropolitan police revealed that
homicides in the popular tourist section
known as the strip have increased that
such health cristian casares
told them that most of these
homicides occurred during the months
of april and august the police say that the
crime rate increased  when
hotels began to reopen and more
criminals from out of state came to
the city so metro has launched
operations to fight crime
so far this year metro has made 44 thousand
stops in the script and have made 8000
arrests and confiscated 600  Guns A
woman is safe and sound this morning
after she was kidnapped by her ex-boyfriend
the incident escalated to a
shooting near charlestown island in
the northeast valley the woman was
kidnapped near lake mls and jones on
tuesday morning police  managed to
locate the couple east of the valley
when officers tried to defuse the
situation the man pointed a gun and
officers fired at him  ron and died at the
scene detectives are still investigating
this case
authorities are looking for the person
responsible for killing a dog
near neil sur and baseball and the
humane society is
offering five thousand dollars for
information that will help apprehend the
suspect if you  you have any kind
of details you are asked to call to
start and the
las vegas convention and visitors authority approved the
sale of the land where
the riviera hotel was previously located on the
streets convention center and las vegas
boulevard near the being that arise and
the  new resort hall an
investment company from chile bought the property
for 120 million dollars the
construction project will begin in 2031 cima
bovina luxury service last night where
fans received the go the nights
with a flourish the knights opened
their fifth season in  full house
facing those who wanted
the game was intense until the final
d  where the knights won by just
1.4 to 3 in their first game of the
season and there is no doubt that fall has
made its presence felt the temperatures have
dropped quite a bit
with highs in the 60s for the
weekend it will get a little hotter
with highs  reaching 80 for
Sunday and next week I am
Cristian Cásseres with his but
informative Spanish naval news good
day